I know you've addressed salary juice before my teen son struggles with acne and I began last
began have began last week I assume taking it. One time I used well-washed non-organic
salary and within an hour he was very exhausted and I became extremely dizzy. Neither of us had had
anything else. The dizziness is better but not God and I have extreme brain fog memory issues as
well. Would you think this is a reaction to metals or pesticides or something else in that salary?
If not then what? If so what should we do? Also are you aware if salary juice has been affected
for cancer, acne or other morbidities that it has claimed to help. It's really hard to say that
your symptoms were a direct result of a drinking that salary juice and it could have been something
in that. A clue gives us that both you and your son may have felt similar after drinking it.
That gives you a clue that it's a greater possibility that that was it. What could have possibly
been in a non-organic salary juice that it could have caused problems? I don't know that I have to
look at the recent dirty dozen list if salary is often sprayed as a gardener. I'm trying to think
why you would spray salary with a pesticide because I don't think there's very many pests that
that bother salary. However definitely if it's not organic they use different fertilizers
to make it grow. Salary is not a super fast growing vegetable. It's really hard to know what could have
caused that. It literally could have become dizzy or exhausted if that was the only thing you drank
like you're on some sort of salary juice vast or something. That's the only thing that you drink.
So, Chrissy said salary is on the dirty dozen list. So yeah, anything is possible. If it was
if it was sprayed with roundup or something like that, if it's on the dirty dozen list, that's
most of the things that the dirty dozen list was sprayed with pesticides like that and herbicides,
then certainly an herbicide could cause issues like that. Anything that crosses the blood-brained
barrier could cause inflammation and the right if it gets worse is that if you already have a
history of brain inflammatory issues, meaning you already had concussions in the past, you already
have known other things that have caused symptoms, brain upper motor type symptoms that would give
you clues that you that you probably already know that you have some primed microglial cells
or worse if you have done a Cyrex array 7x which measures antibodies for neural tissue and it was
and you had any positives of that, then you then anything that could cause inflammation
the brain is going to make that worse. So it's going to take it could take weeks for that to call
them back down. How do you help calm that down? If that's the scenario that you have to use flavonoids
that we've talked about, you know, multiple times, go back and watch the video called
neuroinflammation, it's on the blog, if you just search neuroinflammation on the blog, you'll see
it's about a half hour video that explains microglial priming and the things that you don't want to do
for that. Certainly people that are more sensitive, why doesn't everybody know that I know people
that never eat organic foods, well, they might not be as sensitive to these pesticides and things like
that, they may have an intact blood brain barrier and or they have symptoms of dizziness and
lightheadedness and that's just normal for them so they never think about it. I don't know if there's
all sorts of reasons for that, but certainly if you have a damaged blood brain barrier and you're
exposed to things like that, they're going to cross that barrier.